This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. During the Middle Ages, words spread to Europe about a peculiar plant found in Asia. This plant had a long stock with heavy pods attached. When you cut those pods open, inside you would find a tiny little lamb. Complete with flesh and wool like a live little lamb. Complete with flesh and wool, like a live animal lamb. This creature, half plant, half animal, came to be known as the vegetable lamb of tautry. Various travel writers wrote that they had either heard about this or that they
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在中世纪，欧洲流传着一种关于亚洲某种奇特植物的说法。这种植物长着长长的茎，上面挂着沉重的豆荚。当你切开这些豆荚，里面会发现一只小羊羔。它有血有肉，长着羊毛，就像一只活生生的小羊羔。这种半植物半动物的生物被称为“鞑靼植物羊”。各种旅行作家写道，他们要么听说过这种生物，要么
had eaten one of these lambs. And many of them said they had saw the kind of downy wool from the lamp. When these narratives made their way to Europe people felt they had a view of a different world. Of course no one in Europe had ever seen the vegetable lamb of Tarteri because there was no such thing. But for centuries, people kept talking about this fantastical creature, as if it were real. It even came up in scholarly works, right next to pictures of oak trees and rabbits. If people hadn't been telling each other about these things, nobody would believe that there were vegetable lambs because nobody had ever seen them, right? And this is by no means a unique happening at that time.
吃过这种羊。许多人声称他们见过这种羊身上那种柔软的羊毛。当这些叙述传到欧洲时，人们觉得他们窥见了一个不同的世界。当然，欧洲没有人见过“鞑靼植物羊”，因为根本就没有这种东西。但几个世纪以来，人们一直在谈论这种奇幻的生物，仿佛它是真实存在的一样。它甚至出现在学术著作中，与橡树和兔子的图片并列。如果人们没有互相讲述这些事情，没人会相信有植物羊，因为从来没人见过它们，对吧？这在当时绝非孤例。
At that time, of course, we would never fall for vegetable lambs. We live in an era of science, of evidence-based reasoning, of calm, cool analysis. But maybe there are vegetable lamps that persist even today, even among highly trained, scientists, physicians, and researchers. Maybe there are spectacularly bad ideas that we haven't yet recognized as spectacularly bad. This week on Hidden Brain, we're going to look at how information and misinformation
当然，在那个时代，我们绝不会被“植物羊”所蒙蔽。我们生活在一个科学、循证推理、冷静客观分析的时代。但也许即使在今天，即使在训练有素的科学家、医生和研究人员中，也依然存在着“植物羊”。也许有一些极其糟糕的观点，我们还没有意识到它们有多么糟糕。本周的《Hidden Brain》，我们将探讨信息和错误信息是如何
spread in the world of science and why evidence is often not enough to convince others of the truth. Kaden Okhner is a philosopher and mathematician at the University of California Irvine. She studies how information, both good and bad, can pass from person to person. She is co-author with James Weatherall of the book, The Misinformation Age, How Falls Beliefs Spread. Kaelin, welcome to Hidden Brain. Oh, thank you for having me. So, one of the fundamental premises in your book
在科学界传播的，以及为什么证据往往不足以说服他人相信真相。凯琳·奥康纳是加州大学欧文分校的哲学家和数学家。她研究信息（无论是好是坏）是如何在人与人之间传递的。她与詹姆斯·韦瑟罗尔合著了《错误信息时代：错误信念如何传播》一书。凯琳，欢迎来到《Hidden Brain》。哦，谢谢你邀请我。那么，你们书中的一个基本前提是
is that human beings are extremely dependent on the opinions and knowledge of other people. And this is what creates channels for fake news to flourish and spread. Let's talk about this idea. Can you give me some sense of our dependence on what you call the testimony of others? So one reason we wrote this book is that we noticed that a lot of people thinking about fake news and false belief were thinking about problems with individual psychology. So the way we have biases and processing information, the fact that we're bad at probability.
人类极度依赖他人的观点和知识。这正是假新闻得以滋生和传播的渠道。让我们谈谈这个观点。你能让我了解一下我们对你所说的“他人证言”的依赖程度吗？我们写这本书的一个原因是，我们注意到许多思考假新闻和错误信念的人，都在考虑个人心理层面的问题。比如我们处理信息时存在的偏见，以及我们不擅长概率论的事实。
But if you think about the things you believe, almost every single belief you have has come from another person. And that's just where we get our beliefs because we're social animals and that's really wonderful for us. That's why we have culture and technology, you know, that's how we went to the moon. But if you imagine this social spread of beliefs as opening a door when you open a door for true beliefs to spread from person to person. You also open the door for false beliefs to spread from person to person. So it's this kind of double-sided coin. And what's
但如果你思考一下你所相信的事情，几乎你所有的信念都来自他人。我们之所以获得这些信念，是因为我们是社会性动物，这对我们来说非常棒。这就是我们拥有文化和技术的原因，你知道，这就是我们登上月球的方式。但如果你把这种信念的社会传播想象成打开一扇门，当你打开一扇门让真实信念在人与人之间传播时，你也打开了让错误信念在人与人之间传播的大门。所以这就像一枚硬币的两面。而
interesting of course is that if you close the door you close the door to both and if you open the door you open the door to both. That's right so if you want to be social learners who can do the kinds of cultural things we can do, it has to be the case that you also have to have this channel by which you can spread falsehood and misinformation to. So as I was reading the book, I was reflecting on the things that I know, or the things that I think I know, and I couldn't come up with a good, good answer for how I actually know that it's the earth that revolves around the sun and not the other way around.
有趣的是，如果你关上门，你就同时关上了这两扇门；如果你打开门，你就同时打开了这两扇门。没错，所以如果你想成为能够创造我们所拥有的那种文化的社会学习者，你就必须拥有这种可以传播虚假信息和错误信息的渠道。所以当我在读这本书时，我反思了我所知道的事情，或者我自认为知道的事情，但我无法给出一个很好的答案，说明我究竟是如何知道是地球绕着太阳转，而不是反过来的。
Yeah, that's right. 99% of the things you believe probably you have no direct evidence of yourself. You have to trust other people to find those things out, get the evidence, and tell it to you. And so one thing that we talk a lot about in the book is the fact that we all have to ground our beliefs in social trust. So we have to decide what sources and what people we trust, and therefore what beliefs we're going to take up, because there's just this problem where we cannot go verify everything that we learn directly.
是的，没错。你所相信的99%的事情，你可能都没有直接证据。你必须信任他人去发现这些事情，获取证据，并告诉你。所以我们在书中讨论很多的一点是，我们所有人都必须将我们的信念建立在社会信任之上。因此，我们必须决定信任哪些来源和哪些人，从而决定我们要采纳哪些信念，因为我们面临的问题是，我们无法直接验证我们所学到的一切。
We trust the historian who teaches us about Christopher Columbus. We trust the images from NASA showing how our solar system is organized. Now we say we know Columbus was Italian and we know the earth revolves around the sun. But really what we mean to say is is we trust the teacher and we trust NASA to tell us what is true. And the social trust and ability to spread beliefs, I mean it's remarkable what it's let humans do. You know, no other animal has this ability to sort of transfer ideas and knowledge
我们信任教导我们克里斯托弗·哥伦布的历史学家。我们信任美国国家航空航天局（NASA）展示太阳系结构的图像。现在我们说我们知道哥伦布是意大利人，我们知道地球绕着太阳转。但实际上我们想说的是，我们信任老师，我们信任NASA告诉我们什么是真的。这种社会信任和传播信念的能力，我的意思是，它让人类所做的一切都非常了不起。你知道，没有其他动物有这种能力，能够以某种方式
dependably from person to person over generation after generation to accumulate that knowledge but you do just see sometimes very funny examples of false beliefs being spread in the same way. Now many of us believe there is a way to separate fact from fiction. Science. But as Kaelin points out, science rarely offers permanent truths. Well, first, I would say that in the book, we really encourage trust in science. It's not a book trying to undermine scientific knowledge.
可靠地将思想和知识一代又一代地在人与人之间传递，从而积累这些知识，但你有时确实会看到非常有趣的错误信念以同样的方式传播。现在我们许多人相信有一种方法可以将事实与虚构区分开来：科学。但正如凯琳指出的那样，科学很少提供永恒的真理。嗯，首先，我想说在书中，我们确实鼓励对科学的信任。这不是一本试图破坏科学知识的书。
But if you look at the history of science, there have been a lot of examples of cases where people believe something and then they discovered that that wasn't true. So one classic example is the Myasmatheria of Disease. So before we had the germ theory of disease, everyone thought diseases were caused essentially by bad vapors in the air and that you would have these bad vapors near swamps, for example. But this led to all sorts of problems, of course, for diagnosing various medical issues. If you believe that illness is coming from bad vapors in the air and there's a cholera outbreak, you're not going to go check the local well to see if there's some kind of, you know, germ or bacteria in there. So that's one kind of example. Of course, there have been really dramatic changes in
但如果你看看科学史，有很多例子表明人们相信某件事，后来发现那是不正确的。一个经典的例子是疾病的“瘴气理论”。在细菌致病理论出现之前，每个人都认为疾病本质上是由空气中的恶臭气体引起的，比如沼泽附近的恶臭气体。但这当然导致了诊断各种医疗问题时的各种问题。如果你认为疾病来自空气中的恶臭气体，而此时爆发了霍乱，你就不会去检查当地的水井里是否有某种细菌。这就是一个例子。当然，在
the way we understand the physical world. So Aristotle believed that things fall to the ground because they have the element of earth in them and they're trying to go to their natural position in the center of the earth. Newton argued, no, they fall to the ground because there's a force of gravity that happens between any two massive bodies and it pulls them together. Now we don't believe in that force anymore. We trust Einstein's theory of general relativity, which is that we're all on a curved space time. And when something goes to Earth, it's moving along its natural trajectory in that curved space time.
我们理解物理世界的方式上，确实发生了非常剧烈的变化。亚里士多德认为物体落向地面是因为它们含有土元素，并试图回到它们在地球中心的自然位置。牛顿则认为，不，它们落向地面是因为任何两个有质量的物体之间都存在引力，将它们拉在一起。现在我们不再相信那种力了。我们信任爱因斯坦的广义相对论，即我们都处于弯曲的时空中。当某物落向地球时，它是在那个弯曲的时空中沿着其自然轨迹运动。
As a philosopher of science, Kaelin studies how scientists communicate and share information. If we rely on scientists to tell us what to believe, who do they rely on? Turns out, other scientists. Now showing that this is the case isn't easy. The process by which scientists change their minds on questions such as the spread of disease or the movement of objects through space is very complex. Studying this complex process can be mind-boggling. Say, for instance, Dr. A talks to Dr. B one day about her research. It also turns out that Dr. B is collaborating
作为一名科学哲学家，凯琳研究科学家如何交流和分享信息。如果我们依赖科学家告诉我们该相信什么，那么他们依赖谁呢？事实证明，他们依赖其他科学家。要证明这一点并不容易。科学家在疾病传播或物体在空间运动等问题上改变观点的过程非常复杂。研究这个复杂的过程可能会让人感到头晕目眩。比如，A博士有一天和B博士谈论她的研究。结果发现B博士正在与
with Dr. C, who recently met Dr. D at a conference. Now, Dr. D frequently reads Dr. A's papers, but doesn't know about Dr. C's research. A couple of years later, Dr. E reads what Dr. B has written about what Dr. A said in an article that Dr. C's research. A couple of years later, Dr. E reads what Dr. B is written about what Dr. A said in an article that Dr. C cited before Dr. F had even published her results. Imperically, it's hard to study scientists because things like theory change will happen over the course of 10 or 20 years and involve thousands and thousands of interactions between different scientists.
C博士合作，而C博士最近在一次会议上遇到了D博士。现在，D博士经常阅读A博士的论文，但不知道C博士的研究。几年后，E博士阅读了B博士关于A博士所说内容的文章，而C博士在F博士发表结果之前就引用了该文章。从经验上讲，研究科学家很难，因为理论变革等事情会在10到20年的时间里发生，并涉及不同科学家之间成千上万次的互动。
How would you ever study that? How would you ever study that? Because Kaelin can't follow all these interactions, she recreates them in a computer simulation. You'd want to think of it as a really kind of simplified representation of what's happening in the real world. She creates groups of fictional scientists and she gives them a series of rules like who they can talk to and who they trust.
你怎么可能研究那个呢？你怎么可能研究那个呢？因为凯琳无法追踪所有这些互动，她在计算机模拟中重现了它们。你可以把它看作是对现实世界中正在发生的事情的一种非常简化的表示。她创建了虚构的科学家群体，并给他们制定了一系列规则，比如他们可以和谁交谈，信任谁。
These simulated scientists collect data and discuss their simulated research. Kaelin sits back and watches what happens. Even if you look at completely idealized agents, so you would think of these as simple representations of totally rational scientists or totally rational people testing the world that sometimes they do end up, you know, coming to a false belief about the world, even though they're able to experiment in the model, and they're able to draw really good inferences based on those experiments. Now, one factor in this is that sometimes in the model what you have is spurious results. So if you think about scientific data, usually it's
这些模拟科学家收集数据并讨论他们的模拟研究。凯琳坐下来观察发生了什么。即使你观察完全理想化的主体，也就是你可以把它们看作是完全理性的科学家或完全理性的人在测试世界的简单表示，有时他们最终确实会得出关于世界的错误信念，即使他们在模型中能够进行实验，并且能够根据这些实验得出非常好的推论。现在，其中的一个因素是，有时在模型中你会得到虚假的结果。所以如果你考虑科学数据，通常它是
So if you think about scientific data, usually it's equivocal. You know, it doesn't just tell you what the answer is. If it did, we wouldn't have to do science on it. Instead, it's probabilistic. You have to use statistics to figure out what's true. So one thing we find sometimes in these models is that one agent or scientist will get data supporting the false belief. They'll share it with the entire community of scientists. And then everyone will come to all believe the false thing at once
所以如果你考虑科学数据，通常它是模棱两可的。你知道，它不会直接告诉你答案是什么。如果它能，我们就不需要做科学研究了。相反，它是概率性的。你必须使用统计学来找出真相。所以我们在这些模型中发现的一件事是，有时一个主体或科学家会得到支持错误信念的数据。他们会与整个科学家群体分享。然后每个人都会同时相信那个错误的东西，
and sort of ignore a better theory. And part of what happens there is this social spread of knowledge and belief causing everyone to turn away from a good theory. So if you have almost too much social influence within a community, that can be really bad because everyone can stop gathering data since the entire community is exposed to the same spurious results. You know, we've talked on hidden brain about the psychological reasons people sometimes believe in fake news.
并忽略一个更好的理论。其中发生的一部分是这种知识和信念的社会传播，导致每个人都背离了一个好的理论。所以如果你在一个群体内有太多的社会影响，那可能会非常糟糕，因为每个人都可能停止收集数据，因为整个群体都暴露在相同的虚假结果中。你知道，我们在《Hidden Brain》中讨论过人们有时相信假新闻的心理原因。
We've talked about irrationality and biases and tribalism. We've featured cognitive scientists like Tali Sharat and Danny Kahneman. If I hear you correctly, what you're saying is that psychological factors can have an effect, but you can have the spread of bad information even in the absence of biases or stupidity. Yeah, so one way that the models we look at are really useful, is that you can kind of pair away things that are happening in the real world and see, well, suppose we didn't have any psychological biases, suppose we were perfectly rational, would we always come to the right answer in science and in our day-to-day lives and see that the answer is no?
我们讨论过非理性、偏见和部落主义。我们采访过像塔莉·沙罗特和丹尼·卡尼曼这样的认知科学家。如果我没听错的话，你的意思是心理因素可能会产生影响，但即使在没有偏见或愚蠢的情况下，你也会有错误信息的传播。是的，我们研究的模型之所以非常有用，是因为你可以剥离现实世界中正在发生的事情，看看：假设我们没有任何心理偏见，假设我们是完全理性的，我们在科学和日常生活中是否总是能得出正确的答案？答案是否定的。
day-to-day lives and see that the answer is no. Coming up, how the real world compares to the models that Kaelin bills in her lab. We explore case studies from science that show how good information can sometimes fail to spread, even as bad information metastasizes. Mathematician and philosopher Kailin Okhner studies how information spreads through social networks. People who know and trust one another efficiently pass information back and forth and learn from one another efficiently pass information back and forth and learn from one another. Unfortunately, the same rules of social trust can sometimes be a roadblock for the truth.
日常生活中是否总是能得出正确的答案？答案是否定的。接下来，现实世界与凯琳在实验室中构建的模型相比如何。我们将探讨科学案例研究，展示好的信息有时如何无法传播，即使坏的信息在不断扩散。数学家兼哲学家凯琳·奥康纳研究信息如何在社交网络中传播。相互了解并信任的人高效地传递信息并相互学习。不幸的是，同样的社会信任规则有时会成为真理的障碍。
Mary Wartley Montague learned this lesson hundreds of years ago. She was an English aristocrat who found herself living for a while in what is modern day Turkey. Mary Montague seems to have been really enchanted by Turkish culture. You know, she was coming from England and aristocratic culture there. In Turkey, she discovered these beautiful shopping centers, bath houses.
玛丽·沃特利·蒙塔古在几百年前就学到了这一课。她是一位英国贵族，曾在现代土耳其生活过一段时间。玛丽·蒙塔古似乎真的被土耳其文化所吸引。你知道，她来自英国和那里的贵族文化。在土耳其，她发现了这些美丽的购物中心、浴室。
She seems to have been enchanted by bath houses where there would be a lot of women sort of lounging, naked, going in the hot water, drinking hot drinks together. Another thing that struck Mary about Turkish women, they used an innovative technique to limit the spread of smallpox. It was called Variolation. What this involved, I mean, it's a bit like vaccination now. You would scratch maybe the arm of a patient
她似乎被浴室所吸引，那里有很多女性在休息、赤身裸体、泡在热水里、一起喝热饮。另一件让玛丽对土耳其女性印象深刻的事情是，她们使用了一种创新的技术来限制天花的传播。这被称为“人痘接种法”。这涉及的内容，我的意思是，有点像现在的疫苗接种。你会划破病人的手臂，
and take pus from a smallpox postual and put that pus into the scratch. So what would happen after you did that is that the patient would get a very mild smallpox infection. Some small percentage of patients would die, but many, many fewer than who would die of an actual smallpox infection. And after they had that more mild infection, they would actually be immune to smallpox. So this was practiced commonly in Turkey, basically unheard of in England at the time. Mary Montague had
取天花脓疱中的脓液，然后把脓液放进划痕里。这样做之后，病人会感染非常轻微的天花。一小部分病人会死亡，但比死于实际天花感染的人要少得多。在经历了那种更轻微的感染后，他们实际上会对天花产生免疫力。所以这在土耳其很常见，在当时的英国几乎闻所未闻。玛丽·蒙塔古
herself had smallpox and survived when she was younger. She had lost a brother to smallpox. And so when she encountered variolation in Turkey, she decided, well, you know, why don't we do this in England? She had her own son very elated and she decided she was gonna try to spread this practice in her native country. So when she returns to Britain, in some ways Mary Montague here functions like one of your agents in your computer models
年轻时曾患过天花并幸存下来。她失去了一个死于天花的兄弟。所以当她在土耳其接触到人痘接种法时，她决定，嗯，你知道，为什么我们不在英国这样做呢？她让人给她自己的儿子接种了人痘，并决定要在她的祖国推广这种做法。所以当她回到英国时，在某些方面，玛丽·蒙塔古在这里就像你计算机模型中的一个主体，
because you have one cluster over here in Turkey and one cluster over here in Britain. And essentially you have an agent walking over from Turkey to Britain. And Mary Mont you have an agent walking over from Turkey to Britain. And Mary Montague says, here's this wonderful idea. We can limit the spread of smallpox in Britain. Britain, in fact, at the time was actually facing a smallpox crisis.
因为你这边在土耳其有一个集群，那边在英国有一个集群。本质上，你有一个主体从土耳其走到英国。玛丽·蒙塔古说，这是一个绝妙的主意。我们可以在英国限制天花的传播。事实上，当时的英国正面临天花危机。
How are her ideas received? So her ideas were not received very well when she first came back. One thing we talk a lot about in the book is that almost everyone has what you might call a conformist bias. We don't like to publicly state things that are different from the people in our social networks. We don't like to have beliefs that are different from the people around us.
她的想法是如何被接受的？所以当她刚回来时，她的想法并没有被很好地接受。我们在书中讨论很多的一点是，几乎每个人都有所谓的“从众偏见”。我们不喜欢公开表达与社交网络中其他人不同的观点。我们不喜欢拥有与周围人不同的信念。
It's somehow very socially uncomfortable to do that. And we don't like our actions to not conform with the people who we know and love. So when she got back to England, it was already the case that all these physicians in England didn't believe in variation. They thought this was a crazy idea, and none of them were going to stand out from the
这样做在社交上非常不舒服。我们也不喜欢我们的行为与我们认识和爱的人不一致。所以当她回到英国时，英国所有的医生都已经不相信人痘接种法了。他们认为这是一个疯狂的想法，没有人愿意从
pack of physicians and say, yeah I'm the person who's gonna try this or going to believe that this practice works because they were all busy conforming with each other. And of course these ideas were coming from another country, a country with very different cultural practices that seemed in some ways very foreign. The idea and the country itself seemed very foreign. The idea and the country itself seemed very foreign. That's right. So it's not just that it's a weird new idea that none of them believe in their kind of in-group. It's also that it's coming from Turkey and furthermore it's coming from women in Turkey. So it was a practice mostly done by women and a woman is bringing it to England as well.
医生群体中站出来说，是的，我是那个要尝试这个方法或相信这种做法有效的人，因为他们都忙于互相从众。当然，这些想法来自另一个国家，一个有着非常不同文化习俗的国家，在某些方面看起来非常陌生。这个想法和国家本身看起来都非常陌生。没错。所以这不仅仅是一个他们群体中没人相信的奇怪新想法，它还来自土耳其，而且它来自土耳其的女性。所以这是一种主要由女性完成的做法，而且也是由一位女性带到英国的。
So they also don't really trust her as a woman and someone who's not a physician. So social trust is a really important aspect in understanding how people form beliefs. Because we can't go out and figure out ourselves, whether the things people tell us are true, usually we just always have to decide who to trust. And people have little shortcuts in how they do this. They tend to trust those who are more like them. They also tend to trust those who share beliefs
所以他们也不太信任她，因为她是一位女性，而且不是医生。因此，社会信任是理解人们如何形成信念的一个非常重要的方面。因为我们无法自己去弄清楚别人告诉我们的事情是否属实，通常我们总是必须决定信任谁。人们在这样做时有一些小捷径。他们倾向于信任那些与他们更相似的人。他们也倾向于信任那些分享信念
and values and practices with them. So for example, if you are a physician, you might tend to trust a physician. If you believe in homeopathy, you might tend to trust someone who believes in homeopathy. We all use these kinds of tricks. So what we saw in the variation case with Mary Montague,
和价值观以及习俗的人。例如，如果你是一名医生，你可能倾向于信任医生。如果你相信顺势疗法，你可能倾向于信任相信顺势疗法的人。我们都使用这些技巧。所以我们在玛丽·蒙塔古的人痘接种案例中看到，
the physicians aren't going to trust this woman who doesn't share their beliefs and practices, who isn't much like them. Now you could argue that the physicians who rejected Mary Montague's ideas were not behaving like real scientists. They weren't being dispassionate. They weren't being objective. Theyate, they weren't being objective. They were bringing psychological biases into the picture.
医生们不会信任这个不分享他们信念和习俗、与他们不太像的女人。现在你可以争辩说，拒绝玛丽·蒙塔古想法的医生表现得不像真正的科学家。他们不够冷静。他们不够客观。他们把心理偏见带入了画面。
Sexism, xenophobia, tribalism. In the real world, misinformation spreads because of some combination of network effects and psychological incognitive biases. You see the same thing in the case of the Hungarian physician Ignat Semmelweis. He was an insider, a man, and a doctor. He even had the assistance of scientific evidence to support his claims. But it turned out even these were not enough to overcome the barriers that confront the truth. Ignat Semayas was a physician living in Vienna. He was put in charge of this clinic, the first obstetrical clinic in Vienna.
性别歧视、仇外心理、部落主义。在现实世界中，错误信息的传播是因为网络效应和心理认知偏见的某种结合。你在匈牙利医生伊格纳兹·塞麦尔维斯的案例中也看到了同样的情况。他是一个内部人士，一个男人，一名医生。他甚至有科学证据来支持他的主张。但事实证明，即使这些也不足以克服阻碍真理的障碍。伊格纳兹·塞麦尔维斯是一位住在维也纳的医生。他负责维也纳第一产科诊所。
Next door was the second obstetrical clinic of Vienna. He was in charge of training new doctors and obstetrics, and at the second clinic they were training midwives. And shortly after he took over, he realized that something really terrible was going on because in his clinic, 10% of the women were dying mostly of childbed fever. While the midwives next door, who presumably, they would have thought they were less expertise, only 3 to 4% of their patients were dying. So, Somalwise was obviously really worried about this. He had patients who would be begging on their
隔壁是维也纳第二产科诊所。他负责培训新的产科医生，而第二诊所则在培训助产士。在他接手后不久，他意识到发生了一些非常可怕的事情，因为在他的诊所里，10%的女性死于产褥热。而隔壁的助产士，人们本以为她们的专业知识较少，但她们的病人只有3%到4%死亡。所以，塞麦尔维斯显然对此非常担心。他的病人会跪着
knees to be transferred to the other clinic. He had this kind of breakthrough moment when a colleague of his was conducting an autopsy and accidentally cut himself, and then shortly thereafter he died of something that looked a lot like childbed fever. Some of us realized, well, I've got all these physicians who are conducting autopsy's on cadavers and then immediately going and delivering babies. And he thought, well, maybe there's something transferred on their hands, and he called this cadaverist particles.
乞求被转到另一个诊所。当他的一位同事在进行尸检时不小心割伤了自己，随后不久就死于一种看起来很像产褥热的疾病时，他有了这种突破性的时刻。塞麦尔维斯意识到，嗯，我有这么多医生在尸体上进行尸检，然后立即去接生。他想，也许他们的手上带了什么东西，他称之为“尸体颗粒”。
Of course, now we know that that is bacteria, but they didn't have a theory of bacteria at the time. So he started requiring the physicians to wash their hands in a chlorinated solution, and the death rate in his clinic dropped way down. And of course, the way we think about science, we say, all right, we've someone's discovered something wonderful. Everyone must have instantly adopted this brilliant new idea.
当然，现在我们知道那是细菌，但当时他们还没有细菌理论。所以他开始要求医生用氯溶液洗手，他诊所的死亡率大幅下降。当然，按照我们对科学的思考方式，我们会说，好吧，有人发现了美妙的东西。每个人一定都立刻采纳了这个绝妙的新想法。
You would think, right? And he has this wonderful evidence, right? It was 10%. He introduced the practice goes down to 3%. But that's not what happened. So he published his ideas. And the other gentleman physicians did not take them up. In fact, they found them kind of offensive.
你会这么想，对吧？他有这些美妙的证据，对吧？死亡率是10%。他引入了这种做法，降到了3%。但事实并非如此。所以他发表了他的想法。而其他绅士医生并没有采纳它们。事实上，他们觉得这有点冒犯。
They thought, this is, you know, he's writing that we have dirty hands. We have unclean hands, but in fact, we're gentleman. They also thought it was just really far out of the range of theories that could possibly be true. So, they didn't believe him despite the really good evidence and the deep importance, you know, people's lives were really at stake. And it took, I mean, decades for his handwashing practice to actually spread.
他们认为，他在写我们有脏手。我们有不干净的手，但事实上，我们是绅士。他们还认为这完全超出了可能正确的理论范围。所以，尽管有非常好的证据和深远的重要性，你知道，人们的生命确实处于危险之中，但他们还是不相信他。他的洗手做法实际上花了数十年才传播开来。
In fact, I understand that Semmelweis himself eventually suffered a nervous breakdown. How did his own story end? So the way the story goes, though this is a little hard to verify, is that he was so frustrated that people weren't adopting his handwashing practice that he had a nervous breakdown as a result. He was put into a V&E's mental hospital where he was beaten by guards and died of blood poisoning a few weeks later. We've seen how being an outsider or breaking with tradition can be barriers to the spread of good scientific information.
事实上，我听说塞麦尔维斯本人最终精神崩溃了。他自己的故事是如何结束的？故事是这样的，尽管这有点难核实，他因为人们没有采纳他的洗手做法而感到非常沮丧，结果精神崩溃了。他被送进了一家维也纳的精神病院，在那里被守卫殴打，几周后死于败血症。我们已经看到了作为局外人或打破传统如何成为传播良好科学信息的障碍。
But you could argue that these examples were from a long gone era of gentlemen physicians and amateur scientists. But even in the modern day of science where researchers demand hard evidence to be convinced, it turns out that false, inaccurate and incomplete information can still take hold. In 1954, ED Palmer published a paper that changed how doctors thought about stomach ulcers. So what he did was looked at a lot of stomachs. I believe somewhere in the range of a thousand. And he found that there were no bacteria whatsoever in the stomachs that he
但你可以争辩说，这些例子来自绅士医生和业余科学家的遥远时代。但即使在现代科学中，研究人员要求硬证据才能被说服，事实证明，错误、不准确和不完整的信息仍然可以占据主导地位。1954年，ED·帕尔默发表了一篇论文，改变了医生对胃溃疡的看法。他所做的是观察了大量的胃。我相信在1000个左右。他发现他调查的胃里没有任何细菌。
investigated. A lot of people at that time had been arguing over whether stomach ulcers were caused by stomach acid or some kind of bacteria. This was taken as really decisive evidence showing that, okay, well, it can't be bacteria because everyone thought Palmer's study showed there are no bacteria in stomachs, so it absolutely must be stomach acid. And of course, in this case, Palmer was not trying to fabricate his data or make up data. He was sincerely arriving at what he thought was a very good conclusion. That's right.
当时很多人一直在争论胃溃疡是由胃酸还是某种细菌引起的。这被视为非常有力的证据，表明，好吧，不可能是细菌，因为每个人都认为帕尔默的研究表明胃里没有细菌，所以绝对必须是胃酸。当然，在这种情况下，帕尔默并不是试图捏造数据或编造数据。他真诚地得出了他认为非常好的结论。没错。
And it seems that it just was a problem with his methodology. Of course, there are bacteria in our stomachs. He just didn't see them because of the way he was doing his particular experiment. This was not a fabrication at all. One of the things that's interesting about this episode involving Palmer and the Stomach ulcers is that as individuals essentially came over to believe what Palmer was telling them, there was a consensus that started to grow. And as each new person added to the consensus, it became a little bit stronger, which made it even harder to challenge.
而且这似乎只是他的方法论有问题。当然，我们的胃里有细菌。他只是因为他进行特定实验的方式而没有看到它们。这根本不是捏造。关于帕尔默和胃溃疡的这一集，有趣的一点是，随着个人基本上开始相信帕尔默告诉他们的事情，一种共识开始增长。随着每一个新的人加入到共识中，它变得稍微强了一些，这使得挑战它变得更加困难。
Yeah, so although they had been arguing for decades about whether ulcers were caused by acid or by bacteria, at this point, people started to share palm-ish results pretty much everybody saw them. And this consensus was arrived at okay it's acid and everyone who had been studying the possibility that bacteria caused stomach ulcers stopped studying that and many people turned to looking at okay how can we treat stomach acid in order to treat ulcers. When Australian physician Barry Marshall came along a few decades later to challenge this theory, he was met with stony face resistance. He couldn't get his articles published.
是的，所以尽管他们已经争论了几十年溃疡是由酸还是细菌引起的，在这一点上，人们开始分享帕尔默的结果，几乎每个人都看到了它们。这种共识达成了：好吧，是酸。所有研究过细菌引起胃溃疡可能性的人都停止了研究，许多人转而研究：好吧，我们如何治疗胃酸以治疗溃疡。当澳大利亚医生巴里·马歇尔几十年后挑战这一理论时，他遭到了冷漠的抵制。他的文章无法发表。
Scientists sniped at him behind his back, even though as it turned out, his data was far better than ED Palmer's stomach studies. His data was far better than ED Palmer's stomach studies. Coming up, what Barry Marshall did to fight misinformation and what we can learn from his story about how to spread the truth. The Australian Physician Barry Marshall tried and failed for years to convince doctors that Stamacal sers were caused by bacteria. Like Ignor Simalwise, he found that mere evidence was no match for conventional wisdom. People were bleeding in my practice and dying from ulcers in my hospital. I could see it. match for conventional wisdom. I underwent a baseline endoscopy. I drank the bacteria, tented in the ninth colony forming units.
科学家们在背后对他冷嘲热讽，尽管事实证明，他的数据比ED·帕尔默的胃部研究要好得多。他的数据比ED·帕尔默的胃部研究要好得多。接下来，巴里·马歇尔为了对抗错误信息做了什么，以及我们可以从他的故事中学到什么关于如何传播真相的知识。澳大利亚医生巴里·马歇尔尝试并失败了多年，试图说服医生胃溃疡是由细菌引起的。像伊格纳兹·塞麦尔维斯一样，他发现仅仅有证据根本无法对抗传统智慧。我的病人正在流血，死于溃疡。我能看到。我接受了基线内窥镜检查。我喝下了细菌，含有九个菌落形成单位。
Then I had this vomiting illness, no acid present in my vomit. And when I vomited early in the mornings, still half asleep, but it was just like water coming out. What on earth was he doing, Keena? So he decided that his idea that in fact ulcers are caused by bacteria wasn't spreading fast enough for his taste in the scientific community. And so he did this demonstration. He gave himself H. Pyl, and gave himself stomach ulcers, and then he later cured them
然后我得了呕吐病，呕吐物中没有酸。当我在清晨呕吐时，还在半睡半醒，就像水流出来一样。他到底在做什么，凯琳？所以他决定，他关于溃疡实际上是由细菌引起的想法，在科学界传播的速度不够快，不符合他的口味。于是他做了这个演示。他让自己感染了幽门螺杆菌，让自己得了胃溃疡，然后他后来用抗生素治愈了它们，
with antibiotics in this publicity stunt almost to convince people that in fact ulcers were caused by bacteria. Eventually, Barry Marshall and Robin Warren went on to win the Nobel Prize in Medicine for their discoveries. Mary Martin Giu, the woman who faced resistance in bringing variation to England, never won a prestigious prize, but she also found a way to spread the truth. Like Barry Marshall, she found it had more to do with her sales pitch than with the evidence. So in the end, she did something really smart, which took advantage of the ways that we
这几乎是一场宣传噱头，为了说服人们溃疡实际上是由细菌引起的。最终，巴里·马歇尔和罗宾·沃伦因他们的发现获得了诺贝尔医学奖。玛丽·蒙塔古，那位在将人痘接种法带到英国时面临阻力的女性，从未获得过著名的奖项，但她也找到了传播真相的方法。像巴里·马歇尔一样，她发现这与她的推销方式有关，而不是与证据有关。所以最后，她做了一件非常聪明的事情，利用了我们
use our social connections to ground our beliefs and our trust. So she ended up convincing Princess Carolyn of Onesbach to regulate her own two small daughters and to do it in this kind of public way. So she got one of the most influential people in the entire country to engage in this practice. So that did two things. So number one, it made clear, you know, because she did in this kind of public way and her daughters were fine, it gave people evidence that this is in fact a safe practice and it's a good idea.
利用我们的社会联系来建立我们的信念和信任的方式。所以她最终说服了昂斯巴赫的卡罗琳公主为她自己的两个小女儿接种人痘，并以这种公开的方式进行。所以她让全国最有影响力的人之一参与了这种做法。所以这做了两件事。第一，它很清楚，因为她以这种公开的方式进行，而且她的女儿们很好，它给了人们证据，证明这实际上是一种安全的做法，是一个好主意。
But it also made clear to people that if they want to conform to the norm, if they want to share a practice with this really influential person, then they should do the same thing. And after Princess Carolyn did this, Variation spread much more quickly, especially among people who had a personal connection to either Mary Montague or to the princess. What's fascinating here is that this wasn't in some ways a rational way to solve the problem. It wasn't saying, look, there's really convincing evidence here. You're almost using a technique that's pretty close to propaganda. It is a propaganda technique, absolutely. So,
但它也向人们表明，如果他们想从众，如果他们想与这位非常有影响力的人分享一种做法，那么他们应该做同样的事情。在卡罗琳公主这样做之后，人痘接种法传播得更快了，特别是在那些与玛丽·蒙塔古或公主有个人联系的人中间。这里令人着迷的是，这在某些方面不是解决问题的理性方式。它不是说，看，这里有非常有说服力的证据。你几乎是在使用一种非常接近宣传的技术。这绝对是一种宣传技术。所以，
propaganda technique, absolutely. So, propagandists tend to be very savvy about the ways that people use their social connections to ground trust and knowledge and choose their beliefs, and they take advantage of those. In this case, it was using that social trust for good, but in many cases, people use it for bad. And if you look at the history of industrial propaganda in the US, or if you look at the way Russia conducted propaganda before the last election,
宣传技术，绝对。所以，宣传者往往非常精明，了解人们如何利用他们的社会联系来建立信任和知识并选择他们的信念，他们利用了这些。在这种情况下，它是为了善而利用这种社会信任，但在许多情况下，人们为了恶而利用它。如果你看看美国工业宣传的历史，或者如果你看看俄罗斯在上次选举前进行宣传的方式，
people have taken advantage of these kinds of social ties and beliefs to try to convince us of whatever it is they're selling. One last idea and how you counter bad information. Semilvice as we saw did not succeed in persuading other doctors during his lifetime to wash their hands thoroughly before they were treating patients. But of course, now that idea is widely adopted, what does that tell us, Kaelin, about how signs in some ways might be self-correcting?
人们利用了这些社会联系和信念来试图说服我们相信他们正在兜售的任何东西。最后一个关于如何反击错误信息的想法。正如我们所见，塞麦尔维斯在他有生之年未能成功说服其他医生在治疗病人前彻底洗手。但当然，现在这个想法被广泛采纳了，凯琳，这告诉我们科学在某些方面可能是自我纠正的吗？
It might not be self-correcting at the pace that we want, but over time, it appears that good ideas do beat out the bad ones. Yeah, so we have thousands and thousands of examples in science of exactly that happening, of good ideas beating out the bad ones. Of course, now we can look back and say, oh, well, that could idea one out and that could idea one out. We can't actually look at right now and know which of the ideas we believe now are correct ones or good ones. So there are actually philosophers of science like Larry Loudon and Kyle Stanford who
它可能不是以我们想要的速度自我纠正，但随着时间的推移，好的想法似乎确实胜过了坏的想法。是的，我们在科学中有成千上万个完全符合这一点的例子，好的想法胜过了坏的想法。当然，现在我们可以回顾过去说，哦，那个好的想法赢了，那个好的想法赢了。我们实际上无法审视现在，知道我们现在相信的哪些想法是正确的或好的。所以实际上有像拉里·劳丹和凯尔·斯坦福这样的科学哲学家，
argue for something called the pessimistic meta-induction, which is something like this because scientific theories in the past have always eventually been overturned, we ought to think that our theories now will probably be overturned as well. But there's actually an optimistic side to this, which is that if you look at many theories in the past, ones that were overturned, often the reason people believe them is that even if they were wrong, they were a good guide to action. So Newtonian physics got us to the moon. It's not right, but it was really successful.
他们主张一种叫做“悲观归纳”的东西，大致是这样的：因为过去的科学理论总是最终被推翻，我们应该认为我们现在的理论也可能会被推翻。但实际上这有一个乐观的一面，那就是如果你看看过去的许多理论，那些被推翻的理论，人们相信它们的原因往往是，即使它们是错的，它们也是行动的良好指南。所以牛顿物理学让我们登上了月球。它不完全正确，但它非常成功。
Even the theory of stomach acid causing ulcers, well if you treat stomach acid, it actually does help with ulcers You know, it wasn't a completely unsuccessful theory. It's just that it wasn't totally right and it wasn't as successful as the Bacteria theory of ulcers because antibiotics do better Of course when it comes to something like handhing, you know, you can say that over the last hundred and fifty years, or you know, people have adopted that idea, but it didn't actually mean that the people in Semmelvice's time changed their minds. It really was that those people essentially left the stage and new people came along. There's an old joke in science, which says science progresses funeral by funeral. In some ways, that's what you're talking about here.
即使是胃酸引起溃疡的理论，嗯，如果你治疗胃酸，它确实对溃疡有帮助。你知道，它不是一个完全不成功的理论。只是它不完全正确，而且它不如溃疡的细菌理论成功，因为抗生素效果更好。当然，当谈到像洗手这样的事情时，你知道，你可以说在过去的一百五十年里，人们采纳了那个想法，但这并不意味着塞麦尔维斯时代的人改变了主意。实际上是那些人离开了舞台，新人出现了。科学界有一个古老的笑话，说科学是一场葬礼接着一场葬礼地进步。在某些方面，这就是你在这里谈论的内容。
Yeah, so that can be. So theory change can happen because ideas that are good ideas spread throughout a community and then more people start to test them and then they communicate them to more people. And eventually you reach a consensus. One thing that the philosopher Thomas Kuhn really argued is that when you're having these kind of big paradigm shifts in science often it's young people coming up with a new paradigm and then switching to it because they don't have any skin in the game in the old one You know they haven't spent their life
是的，所以可能是这样。所以理论变革可以发生，因为好的想法在整个群体中传播，然后更多的人开始测试它们，然后他们把它们传达给更多的人。最终你达成共识。哲学家托马斯·库恩真正主张的一点是，当你在科学中进行这种大的范式转移时，往往是年轻人提出了一个新的范式，然后转向它，因为他们在旧的范式中没有任何利益相关。你知道，他们没有花一生时间
defending this older theory and then you know maybe eventually the people who are defending metal or theory, retire or die. And then you have theory change. One of the interesting implications about all of this is how we should think about the truth. And in some ways, I think the picture that I'm getting from you is a picture that says the truth is not a binary question. It's not, you know, is it true? Is it false? I mean, some questions, of course,
捍卫这个旧理论，然后，你知道，也许最终那些捍卫旧理论的人退休或去世了。然后你就有了理论变革。关于这一切的一个有趣的含义是我们应该如何思考真理。在某些方面，我认为我从你那里得到的图景是，真理不是一个二元问题。它不是，你知道，它是真的吗？它是假的吗？我的意思是，当然，有些问题
perhaps can be reduced to, is it true? Is it false? But really, scientists in the business are producing probability estimates for various claims. And I think what you're saying is that for us to actually be on the right side of the misinformation, information divide, it's helpful for us to think in probabilistic terms rather than in binary terms. Yeah, that's absolutely right. So we do think it's really important to think about belief in terms of degrees and evidence and believing something strongly enough. And part of the reason is that there has been this strategy where people who are trying to subvert our beliefs will say, but we're not sure about something.
也许可以简化为：这是真的吗？这是假的吗？但实际上，业内科学家正在为各种主张提供概率估计。我认为你所说的是，为了让我们真正站在信息鸿沟正确的一边，用概率而非二元对立的思维方式去思考是有帮助的。是的，完全正确。所以我们确实认为，根据证据的程度来思考信念，并相信到足够的程度是非常重要的。部分原因是，那些试图颠覆我们信念的人采取了一种策略，他们会说，我们对某件事并不确定。
They'll say, evolution's just a theory, or there's some doubt about global warming. But ultimately not being sure about something is not what matters. We're never really 100% sure about anything. And if you think about it, think about any belief you could have, you know, that the sun will come up tomorrow. Well, it always has in the past, but that doesn't mean that 100% sure it will tomorrow.
他们会说，进化论只是一个理论，或者对全球变暖存在一些怀疑。但归根结底，对某事不确定并不是问题的关键。我们永远无法对任何事情百分之百确定。如果你仔细想想，想想你可能拥有的任何信念，比如，明天太阳会升起。嗯，过去它总是升起，但这并不意味着明天百分之百会升起。
There's a really good chance it will tomorrow. We shouldn't be looking for certainty. Instead, we need to be saying to ourselves, when do we have enough evidence to make good decisions? Kaelin O'Connor is a philosopher and mathematician at the University of California, Irvine. She studies how social networks can spread both good information and bad. Along with James Weatherall, she is co-author of the book, The Misinformation Age,
明天它升起的可能性非常大。我们不应该寻求确定性。相反，我们需要问自己，我们何时才有足够的证据来做出正确的决定？凯琳·奥康纳是加州大学欧文分校的哲学家和数学家。她研究社交网络如何传播好信息和坏信息。她与詹姆斯·韦瑟罗尔合著了《错误信息时代》一书，
How Falls Beliefs Spread. Kaelin, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Kaelin, thank you so much for having me. This week's show was produced by Kimela Vargas Restrepo and edited by Tara Boyle and Jenny Schmidt. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Laura Quarelle, Parts Shah and Thomas Liu. Our unsung heroes this week don't work at Hidden Brain or even at NPR, but the longer we do this show, the more we realize how many helping hands go into building it. We often found we turn to the
《错误信念是如何传播的》。凯琳，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。凯琳，非常感谢你的邀请。本周的节目由基梅拉·瓦尔加斯·雷斯特雷波制作，塔拉·博伊尔和珍妮·施密特编辑。我们的团队成员包括雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、帕茨·沙和托马斯·刘。我们本周的无名英雄并不在《隐藏的大脑》或美国国家公共电台工作，但我们做这个节目越久，就越意识到有多少双援手在帮助我们。我们经常发现我们求助于
scientists and forecasters at the National Weather Service to tell us when we need to get an episode wrapped up by Friday because it's a storm arriving on Monday that could keep us from getting to the office. Government departments like the National Oceanic and Atmospheric Administration do their work so quietly and so well, we often take them for granted. Today we recognize the folks at NOAA as it's called for their vital work. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. You can find information about the research we discussed on this show on our website, npr.org slash hidden brain. If you liked this episode, please think of one
国家气象局的科学家和预报员，让他们告诉我们什么时候需要在周五前完成一期节目，因为周一可能会有风暴，导致我们无法去办公室。像美国国家海洋和大气管理局这样的政府部门工作得如此安静且出色，我们往往认为这是理所当然的。今天，我们要感谢美国国家海洋和大气管理局（NOAA）的工作人员，感谢他们的重要工作。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请关注我们的Facebook和Twitter。你可以在我们的网站npr.org/hiddenbrain上找到我们节目中讨论的研究信息。如果你喜欢这一集，请想一想
friend who might enjoy our show and drop them a word about it. I'm Shankar Vittantum and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
可能会喜欢我们节目的朋友，并向他们推荐一下。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台。这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。